[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hello it's getting close to
the end of the year
yes what a year this has been it's been
an amazing year
yes let's get right into it i'll open
with the word
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us together thank you for
keeping us this whole year and thank you
for giving us the
privilege of doing these discussions we
once again ask that you
bless the discussion and all always
enlighten our minds with the holy spirit
in jesus name amen
amen
martin we have been threatening to talk
about
heaven for a long long time i think
more or less since episode one yes and
we would get there
every time we're gonna get there yes
because it's part of the book of
revelation as well
as many as well as many other places in
the bible
but we've had so much bad news in this
year
which is actually exciting news and
if rightly interpreted not really bad
news but good news
yes because it means that we're we're
coming to a climax
yeah we're getting there heading and
today and we have finally got to the
point where we can actually talk about
heaven but before we get to heaven we
first have to
go through a bump or two right yes
and we've titled this one heaven is real
because there are so many theories out
there where they allegorize the stories
and spiritualize them yes and then
nothing is reality everything is ghostly
and there's nothing really that you can
you know tangibly
touch and uh the book of hebrews
tells us in chapter 11 that faith is the
substance of things hoped for
the evidence of things not seen
not seen yes so it is
tangible it is substance
of those things that you hope for and
evidence
of those things that you haven't seen so
let's jump into it and we'll start with
with john chapter 14 because to me
john chapter 14 from verse 1 has always
been
a mini summary of the entire bible yeah
it's a beautiful book it's a beautiful
verse isn't
it there's so much doctrine in this
verse
that if people would only believe it and
not spiritualize it the way
they would not be so confused
uh you told us in your in your testimony
that this had quite an effect on you
yes there's a huge effect on it because
it solved your
your sleep and death and all those
issues
yeah right let not your hearts be
troubled do you believe in god
believe also in me in my father's house
are
many mansions depending what uh
transformation you have the king james
gives you mansions the others give you
houses and some only give you
rooms and some give you some space
and let's stick to this one in my
father's house or many mansions if it
were not so i would have told you
i go to prepare a place for you and if i
go and prepare a place for you i will
come again and receive you unto myself
that way i
am there ye may be also
and whether i go ye know and the way you
know now we know the way
because he is the way the truth and the
life we have to believe in him
he said he was going to come again and
so he will come again if you believe in
him
yes he said he was going to prepare a
place for us
a physical place and he will come so
that we can live where he lives to
yes and he didn't ascend into heaven as
a ghost because
the angel said the same jesus the one
that just
ate out of your hands this same
jesus will come in like manna in like
manner
also the way he went correct in the air
so
no spiritualization like the spiritus do
like blavatsky wants everybody to
believe
that this is the ushering in of a new
age a spiritual
age there is no real christ he was
overshadowed all this nonsense
this is a literal explanation no
change in your mind from 3d to 5d
nothing this is a world of reality
now the new heaven and the new earth
revelation 21 verse 1 says
and i saw a new heaven and a new earth
for the first heaven and the first earth
were passed away
and there was no more sea
now the ocean of course was what
uh came after the flood there was no
ocean before
but there were huge inland lakes and
rivers and must have been very beautiful
oceans separate people so
there will be no more separation there
will no more even if you take it
in the prophetic sense the the oceans
the waters the sea
or nations yeah we will be
one we will still have nations it will
still have your identity
but you won't be separated into
blocks where you have to cross borders
right
and here's a statement from the spirit
of prophecy the lord
is soon to come there must be a refining
a winnowing process in every church
for there are among us wicked men who do
not love the truth or honor
god we are in the shaking time the time
when everything that can be shaken will
be shaken
the lord will not excuse those who know
the truth if they do not in word
and deed obey his commands
testimonies to the church volume 6 page
and this is of course true because the
bible says there will be a judgment
so there is some work to be done
some refining of carry character
and the church right now mustn't be
judged by the people that
are in the church because there are
even wicked men i mean we've been saying
this numerous times
yes so we must look at
what is taught yes and not look at the
individuals
and even the best of men and women
have bad days and we have to forgive
each other
until probation close closes seventy
times seven
times so james admonishes us in chapter
five
be patient therefore brethren unto the
coming of the lord
behold the husband man waiteth for the
precious fruit of the earth and has
long patience for it until he received
the early and the latter rain
so the church will go through a process
there was an early rain
when the church was founded and there
will be a latter rain
when the final message goes to the world
but we have to be patient establish your
hearts for the coming of the lord
draweth nigh
grudge not one against another brethren
lest you be condemned
behold the judge standeth before the
door
now this entire year we've been talking
about the signs of the times
we've been talking about the nations are
angry
we've been talking about legislation
that suppresses
your individuality
that threatens your very current
exercise your freedom
everything but these are signs
that we should actually
really be working at our hearts yes
though that verse nine grudge not
against
another yeah and i think the closer we
get to the end
the more prevalent it will be that you
have to do that because it's gonna get
so much worse the friction is gonna get
so much
and there will be a tremendous shaking
and we can already see it i mean there
are people that
even within the church that are at
loggerheads about
issues of doctrine and they're so
militant about
all of these things and there will be a
last call
for humanity god has called this people
to give to the world the message of
christ's soon coming
we are to give to men the last call to
the gospel feast
the last invitation to the marriage
supper of the lamb
thousands of places that have not heard
the call or
yet to hear it this is where the
internet comes in right
it's really reaching places that nothing
else can
internet and cell phones
yes many who have not given the message
or yet to proclaim it
again i appeal to our young men has not
god
called upon you to sound this message
this is a reality that we're talking
about
not a spiritual shift in dimension
and time this is a real
world and we are admonished to talk it
to pray it and to believe it
the lord is soon coming talk it pray it
believe it
make it part of the life you will have
to meet a
doubting objecting spirit but this will
give way
before firm consistent trust in god
when perplexities or hindrances present
themselves
lift the soul to god in song and
thanksgiving
gird on the christian armor and be sure
that your feet are shot with the
preparation of the gospel of
peace preach the truth with boldness and
fervor remember that the lord looks in
compassion
upon this field and that he knows its
poverty and its need
the efforts you are making will not
prove a failure
we must tell people that
what we believe is a reality it has
substance
it's not an airy fairy something and
this also tells us to keep
um keep hope and keep the faith
absolutely don't give up because
a lot of times especially these days
you get discouraged when bringing the
good news to somebody
yes and there's so much opposition
position
so be filled with joy we should be
filled with joy at the thought of christ
soon appearing
to those that love his appearing he will
come without sin
unto salvation so you must love his
appearance i mean that's a bible verse
that's being quoted
quoted right there you must love his
appearing
people always say i'm not ready i don't
want him to come
no you'll never be ready never be ready
you'll never be around
if you don't start looking forward to it
when are you going to
look forward to it no no what generation
will finally say okay we're ready yes
we're looking forward to it not gonna
happen
but if our minds are filled with the
thoughts of earthly things we cannot
look forward with joy to his appearing
now the world is really helping us there
because they're taking away all the joy
of being on this planet
yes so that you know people will start
thinking about heavenly things
it'll be a glorious day of victory we
must not forget that now the church is
militant
now we are confronted with a world in
darkness
almost wholly given over to idolatry
but the day is coming when the battle
will have been fought the victory one
the will of god is to be done in
on earth as it is done in heaven
so this heaven that we are reading about
there must be a real
place because earth is a real place
you can't um compare it with earth
and then all of the sudden once you've
gone from the literal earth you go to
the spiritual heaven
exactly all will be a happy united
family
clothed with the garments of praise and
thanksgiving
the robe of christ's righteousness all
nature in its super
surpassing loveliness will offer to god
a tribute of praise and adoration
the world will be bathed in the light of
heaven the light of the moon will be as
the light of the sun and the light of
the sun will be seven-fold greater than
it is now
the years will move on in gladness over
the scene the morning stars will sing
together and the songs of god will
shout for joy while god and christ will
unite in proclaiming there shall be no
more sin
neither shall there be any more death
these are literal promises
if you believe in reincarnation you
believe in perpetual death
but the bible says it is given for man
wants to die and thereafter the judgment
so you're immortal but you're immortal
in hell
exactly that doesn't make sense no
that's the one doctrine the other one is
that you come back and
come back and come back yeah and uh
have this eternal battle against your
alter ego
in the quotation she mentions that this
moon will be as bright as the sun and
the sun will be seven times more
but there's also a part in revelation
that says the sun won't be necessary
yes well obviously in the city
the light will be christ himself and he
outshines the sun
so you won't need the sun in the city
doesn't mean that it won't be there
it will be there in the rest of the
world
but it will be seven times brighter in
other words and the moon will be like
the sun
so what we consider light today
in terms of heaven is actually darkness
our eyes
will have to be re-organized
and recreated in order to cope with that
so we'll come to that later that's fine
it will it actually says there won't be
any darkness if the moon is like the sun
absolutely no way ephesians 3 verse 7
whereof i was made a minister according
to the gift of
the grace of god given unto me by the
effectual working of his power
and to me who am less than the least of
all the saints is this grace given that
i should preach amongst the
gentiles the unsearchable riches of
christ that's actually everybody's duty
we are all sinners and yet
he has chosen a fallen humanity to
proclaim his glory
and to make all men see what is the
fellowship of the mystery
which from the beginning of the world
has been hid in god who created
all things by jesus christ to the intent
that
now unto the principalities and powers
in heavenly places might be made known
by the church
the manifold wisdom of god
so there's this conflict between the
doctrine
of devils and the doctrine of god
the church has been given the doctrine
of god
and the devil has the occupation of
preaching the doctrine of devils and
people must make a choice between the
two
according to the eternal purpose which
he purposed in christ jesus our lord
in whom we have boldness and access with
confidence by the faith of him
wherefore i desire that you faint not
that my tribulation for you
which is your glory so don't look
at individuals and say well if this one
is going through so much tribulation
what kind of god is he serving right
yeah or
like people say all the time where's god
in all of this
yes the very fact that it's such a mess
means that god is working right and it
means that he's
reliable because he said it will be like
this exactly
now before this great event takes place
there will be this final message that
goes up
and there'll be this contrast between
light and darkness
and there will be a final
great tribulation and plagues now we're
not going to deal with them i'm just
going to read a little bit of revelation
chapter 15
and i saw another sign in heaven great
and marvelous
seven angels having the seven last
plagues for in them is filled up the
wrath of god
and i saw as it were a sea of glass
mingled with fire
and them that had gotten the victory
over the beast and over his image
and over the mark and over the number of
his name
stand on the sea of glass having the
harps of god
and they sing the song of moses the
servant of god and the sing the song of
the lamb
saying great and marvelous are thy works
lord god almighty
just and true are thy ways thou king of
saints
who shall not fear thee o lord and
glorify thy name
for thou only art holy for all nations
shall come and worship before thee
for thy judgments are made manifest
so after the plagues there
will be a resurrection of the righteous
dead
the righteous living will be translated
in the moment in a twinkling of an eye
they will meet the lord in the air and
they will stand on the sea of glass
and they will sing the song of moses
which was
a song of physical deliverance
from bondage and they will sing the song
of the lamb
which is also a deliverance
from bondage in terms of sin you have
the righteousness back so you have
all of these intermingled you have this
physical salvation
from bondage physical bondage and you
have the spiritual
release from the bondage of sin
so they'll sing both songs it's
beautiful beautiful
and the lord will be the one who is the
judge
and after that i looked and behold the
temple of the tabernacle of the
testimony
in heaven was opened so you actually see
the law of god
which was the standard of judgment
and the seven angels came out of the
temple having the seven plagues clothed
in pure
and white linen and having their breasts
girded with golden girdles
and one of the four beasts gave unto the
seven angels
seven golden vials full of the wrath of
god
who liveth forever and ever and the
temple was filled with
smoke from the glory of god and from his
power
and this is a very important sentence
and no man was able to enter into the
temple
till the seven plagues of the seven
angels were fulfilled
you know we have this theology in the
world
that when you die you go to heaven yes
now we saw in the very first verse
that you go to heaven when he comes
again right yes
that's what you discovered yes i come to
come and fetch you
just be where i am so that you can be
where i am also and here again it is
reiterated
that nobody goes to heaven until the
seven plagues have fallen
so just like literal israel was
on this earth and had to go through
that experience it's interesting there
were ten plagues in egypt right
the first three affected both the
egyptians and the israelites but
seven only affected the
egyptians and here there are only seven
so that's actually a promise that god's
people
won't be affected by the plagues only
the wicked
but they will go through it they will go
through it yes and
nobody enters until they have fallen so
it's exactly
antitype of what happened in typical
egypt with a physical deliverance
so also this
makes of null and void the rapture
theology absolutely so that there is a
pre-rapture
and then there is a conversion here that
doesn't take place
because nobody can enter their place
correct
ephesians chapter 2 from verse 4 but god
who is rich in
mercy for his great love wherewith he
loved us
even when we were dead in sins has
quickened us together with christ
by grace you are saved and has raised us
up together and made us sit together in
heavenly places
in christ jesus that in the ages to come
he might show the exceeding riches of
his grace
in his kindness towards us through
christ jesus
this is a very interesting verse when
you become converted
you actually partake of heaven already
through your faith in christ and through
your faith in what is to come
but then faith must meet
substance that's the definition
if it remains faith then you have a
spiritual world a spiritualized world
whereas here it says in the ages to come
he might show the exceeding riches of
his grace and his kindness towards us
through jesus christ chapter 3 verse 10
says to the intent that now unto the
principalities and powers and heavenly
places might be made known by the church
what the manifold wisdom of god is
so there is a future to look forward to
but now we are in the preaching phase
we're not in the
in the physical experiencing phase but
the whole
experience is starting now absolutely
so in your mind even when
the turmoil is around you you can
actually
be in heavenly places and you make that
makes it so important
to realize that your way to heaven
starts here yes so it's not
by a change all of a sudden now i'm
going to be ready and now i'm going to
enjoy heaven exactly
if you don't start this side already
of heaven aligning your thoughts and so
and your life
and so on with the type of life in
heaven
there's going to be too much of a gap
to go to him exactly
we are still amidst the shadows and
turmoils of earthly activities
let us consider most earnestly the
blessed here
after let our faith pierce through every
cloud of darkness and behold him who
died for the sins of the world
he has opened the gates of paradise to
all who receive
and believe in him isn't that beautiful
very beautiful to them he gives power to
become the sons and daughters of god
let the afflictions which paint us so
grievously become
instructive lessons teaching us to press
forward towards the mark of the prize of
our high calling in christ
let us be encouraged by the thought that
the lord is soon to come
let this hope gladden our hearts yet a
little while and he
that shall come will come and will not
tarry hebrews 10
37 blessed are those servants who
when their lord comes shall be found
watching
this is the attitude we must have now
and the worse it gets the more our
attitude should be focused on this issue
exactly
let it be instructive lessons
yes let it be instructive lessons you
know this is not only a coping mechanism
because this is actually a reality it is
something to look forward to
once i have been through this desert
there's an oasis on the other side isn't
it
i know i live like if there's something
to look forward to
then i can so much more cope with what's
going on exactly if you have the end of
the year
holiday to look for this the last two
months of the year become bearable
okay because you've got something to do
because you think that's something to
look forward to
so i think that's how you should look at
evan as well yes so we're homeward bound
we're home with bound he who loved us so
much as to die for us
has built it for us a city a real city
do you believe that yes do you believe
that a real city is going to come down
on this earth like a huge mega spaceship
and come and land on this earth
are you insane that's what people will
say right
well now with god all things are
possible aren't they
yes the new jerusalem
is our place of rest there will be no
sadness in the city of god
no wail of sorrow no dirge of crushed
hopes and buried affections
will ever more be heard soon the
garments of heaviness will be changed
for the wedding garment
soon we shall witness the coronation of
our king
i cannot wait for that king a king of
righteousness
as opposed to what the world dishes up
right now
yeah a leader that will come and
everything
he promised he actually will come and
deliver
those whose lives have been hidden with
christ
those who on this earth have fought the
good fight of faith
will shine forth with the redeemer's
glory
in the kingdom of god
it will not be long till we shall see
him in whom we are hopes of eternal life
are centered and in his presence all the
trials and sufferings of this life
will be as nothingness
cast not away therefore your confidence
which has great recompense of reward for
you have
need of patience that after you have
done the will of god you might receive
the promise for
yet a little while and he that shall
come
will come and will not tarry look up
look up and let your faith continually
increase
let this faith guide you along the
narrow path that leads through the gates
of the city of god into the great beyond
the wide
unbounded future of glory that is for
redeemed
be patient therefore brethren unto the
coming of the lord behold the husbandman
waiteth for the precious fruit of the
earth and has
long patience for it until you receive
the early and the latter rain
be also patient establish your hearts
for the coming of the lord
draweth nigh james 5 7-8
actually that's a compilation of bible
verses
yes and it is so
beautifully strung together that it
makes a story
of a reality which men have lost
sight of correct do you know that song
heaven is a place on earth
god forbid that heaven should be a place
on earth
as the ransom ones are welcome to the
city of god
their rings out amongst the air an
exultant cry of adoration
the two atoms are about to meet that
must be quite a moment right
the son of god is standing with
outstretched arms to receive the father
of our race
the being whom he created who sinned
against his maker
and for whose sin the marks of the
crucifixion are born upon the savior's
form
as adam discerns the prince of the cruel
nails he does not fall upon the bosom of
his lord but in humiliation casts
himself at his feet crying
worthy worthy is the lamb that was slain
tenderly the savior lifts him up and
bids him
look once more upon the eden home from
which he has so
long been exiled an allegory
no you believe it i believe it i believe
it's tangible and it will be a reality
okay and that will be wonderful so what
does the bible tell us about
heaven we must talk about heaven we've
now been through the plagues again
unfortunately there's always some thorns
that you have to get through to go to
this
when she was a child she didn't like
uh stiff porridge and so
her parents or mother always told her
that if she wants to get they were
atheists actually they were mocking
right
they were saying if you want to get to
heaven you have to eat through a wall
of porridge
[Laughter]
the new heaven and the new earth now
revelation chapter 21
is actually a beautiful chapter and
we've spoken so much about revelation
and we might as well finish it right we
might as well
read the good news yeah we've been in
revelation
13 we've been in revelation 11 and
14 and 15 and 16 and 17 and
plagues and and uh masks and
uh viruses and
and pandemics and you name it but uh
this is just as real as anything else
right correct
and i john saw the holy city the new
jerusalem coming down from god
out of heaven prepared as a bride
adorned
for a husband he sees a literal city
and i heard a great voice out of heaven
saying behold the tabernacle of god is
with men
and he will dwell with them and they
shall be his people and god himself
shall be with them and be their god
you will see god face to face he will
literally
be amongst his people no more veil
and god shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes
and there shall be no more death neither
sorrow nor
crying neither shall there be any more
pain for the former things are passed
away
can you imagine a god like that
now in an earthly situation when a child
falls and hurts itself and a parent
picks that child up and comforts it
that's sort of a mini representation
of a much greater reality
and he that sat upon the throne said
behold
i make all things new and he said unto
me write for these
words are true and faithful this is not
an allegory
you can't believe it this is a reality
and there came unto me one of the seven
angels which had the seven
vials full of the seven last plagues and
he talked with me saying come heather
and i will show you the bride
the lamb's wife so you have a contrast
these were the very angels that brought
about a great destruction
and now they're showing the reward
you have this contrast and he carried me
away in the spirit to the great and high
mountain and showed me that great city
the holy jerusalem descending
out of heaven from god so this is not
talking about a jerusalem
that is somewhere in the middle east
that is not from heaven but is from
this earth down here no
having the glory of god and a light was
like unto a stone most
precious even like a jasper stone clear
as crystal
and then it describes the city it had 12
gates and the tribes were
names of the tribes were written on it
and
it had the east gates and three in the
north
etc and the walls of the city had 12
foundations and on them were the 12
apostles of the lamb
showing the inseparate nature
of the old and the new covenant
the old and the new testament wow
and the city was measured and the gates
thereof and the wall thereof
and the city lies four square and the
length is as large as the breadth
and he measured the city with the re 12
000 furlongs the length of the breadth
and the height of it
are equal so now there's some
speculation
about what this this is enormous yeah
this city is large enough to hold the
entire population
of humanity it's a huge city
and it's incredibly high hundreds of
kilometers high
now this city is built in a square
and the sides of the of the square are
of course
equal but it is as high as
it is wide now what is it
is it a cube or is it a pyramid
the pyramid it could be a pyramid right
because that would also
be the same thing now if you go to the
pyramids that's exactly how they are
designed
now there is one who is
a counterfeit the one who believes that
he is the prince of this world
and he tries to counterfait the things
of god and the pyramid
is his structure it's one it's so
occultic and everything he's totally
swung it on his way yes can it be a cube
as well
it could be a cube because it's as wide
as it is high
now in the occult you also have cubes
that they use
but my personal feeling is maybe maybe
it's a pyramid
but i'm not going to be dogmatic on that
one right
and he measured the wall there of 144
cubits according to the measure of a man
that is of the angel
and the walls are incredibly
thick and the building of the wall
is of jasper and the city was pure gold
like unto clear
glass so the gold is so pure that you
can actually
look through it amazing
and then it talks about the foundation
of the city they were garnished with all
kinds of precious stones
and you know there's a video going
around about the nature of these stones
that are
that are meant there it's interesting
that what is the most precious thing on
earth is not there the diamond
and it has to do with the breaking index
of light
and precious stones have one quality
these precious stones have one quality
and the others have different qualities
and
there there are lots of stories about
that but what's interesting
is that there are no diamonds now
diamond is compressed
carbon right and debris
yes and a diamond is formed when you
have
tremendous pressure in volcanic
tubes and that compresses
the carbon so the diamond is actually a
post flood
phenomenon yeah it's a catastrophic
element it's interesting that a product
of catastrophe
should be the most precious thing on
this earth
but these stones reflect
the light and are translucent to the
light
and these are the real precious stones
that will be
there so you have the jasper and the
sapphire and the
all of these and the emerald and it
mentions all the stones
and the gates are pearls now pearl
in this world is formed when there is an
irritant
in the creature like a grain of sand and
it covers it over to be made
smooth so a pearl is a symbol
of a beautiful product that came out of
suffering
so it's a nice symbol of what the gates
are made of
the gates are a beautiful symbol
of a great suffering that has been
experienced by all i saw no temple
therein for the lord god almighty and
the lamb are the temple
we are worshiping a real god we're not
going to be
subject to specific buildings but we
have a face-to-face contact
and it had no need of the sun neither of
the moon
because the glory of the lord lighted it
that doesn't mean there won't be a sun
like you said earlier this is in the
city correct
and the nations of them which are saved
shall walk in the light of it and the
kings of the earth to bring their glory
and honor into it and the gates of it
shall
not be shut at all by day
and there shall be no night there so you
have free access
no lockdown there's no luck down in the
city the
the gates are open if you want to visit
someone
you can go no mask either no mask no
no because you'll see face to face
and they shall bring the glory and honor
of the nations into it and there shall
in no wise enter into it anything that
defileth
neither whatsoever worketh abomination
or maketh a lie but they which are
written in the lamb's book of life
so there has to be some character
development
if you want to be part of this
now if we go to some other portions of
the bible we
can glean some more information now
we want to get into what the city will
be like
we want to speculate a little right
and some people will say oh they're
conspiratorial even when
when it comes to this when it comes to
the history but that's fine
let those that are so narrow-minded that
they cannot think outside the box
remain in their box and we'll we'll as
long as they're happy in their box right
isaiah 11 6 says the wolf also shall
dwell with the lamb
and the leopard shall lie down with the
kid and the cough and the young lion
and the fatling together and a little
child
shall lead them now i gave a lecture
many years ago called creation to
restoration
where i look at the scientific aspects
of the animals that are now carnivorous
yes that originally were probably not
carnivorous
and we looked at some scientific
evidence for that
and some experiments that we've even
done and
maybe you can put a link in linking to
that yeah creation to restoration
you also mentioned in that one if i
remember correctly that the lion for
instance
the first thing it eats is the stomach
yes the the strong line gets gets the
stomach on
it actually almost makes him also yeah
her beverage is some extent
correct now there are two things that
happen here they change their diets
and they change their dispositions they
become
gentle and mild there's no more
aggression
because even a little child will lead
them
humanity is back in charge and the
animals
are gentle and loving
and playful and kind and the cow and the
bear shall feed their young ones shall
lie down together and the lion
shall eat straw like the ox
we have little glimpses of that in the
world
you know if a cat and a dog become
friends they become inseparable
yeah and you have these trance species
relationships of animals and even
lions adopting a little buck
yeah so there are very strange stories
out there which tell us
that originally yeah there are glimpses
in a sick world and the sucking child
shall play in the whole of the asp and
the weaned child shall put his hand on
the cockroach's
den in other words the snake will no
longer be poisonous it will be
restored to whatever beauty it had
before
and they shall not hurt nor destroy in
all my holy mountain for the earth shall
be full of the knowledge of the lord as
the waters cover the sea
so what will our relationship be like
with the animal world
very intertwined and
indescribable yeah you will have a
relationship
like you can only dream of in this world
where we only have
many glimpses of a greater reality
now we see through a glass darkly but
then we will see
as it really is um i'm sure we'll also
see
animals that are now extinct absolutely
dinosaurs i cannot wait to slide down
the brontosaurus's neck
and then we will be active you will have
a house in the city
because the lord is preparing a dwelling
place but when the earth is made new
after the thousand years
then you will build houses and you will
inhabit them and you shall plant
vineyards and eat the fruit of them
in other words you will have a city
house
a city dwelling and you will have a
country dwelling
and whatever that is what will happen
you will build and not another inhabit
there will be no government regulation
which disinherits you
no fines for moving dead trees nothing
no fines for moving dead trees that was
a very
interesting moment in my life to be
fined for moving a dead tree
unbelievable
they shall not plant and another eat oh
i'm sorry but there won't be any dead
trees there won't be any dead trees to
move
yes you're right they will not plant an
another eat
that's interesting now in other words
won't be active in heaven it will be
part of history
one part will be a little bit true there
will be no borders
that's correct as for the days of a tree
or the days of my people and my
lecture long enjoy the works of their
hands
this means that you will
actually be able to enjoy the fruits of
your labor
but you're welcome to come and eat
one of my avocados as long as you don't
overdo it okay
they shall not labor in vain nor bring
forth for
trouble for they are the seed of the
blessed of the lord and their offspring
is with them
this is a reality this is what heaven is
going to be like
this is not a spiritual
cloud9 sitting with a with a musical
instrument a heart heavenly knowledge
will be
progressive all the treasures of the
universe will be open
to the study of god's redeemed
unfettered by mortality
they wing their tireless flight to
worlds afar
everybody wants to have
extraterrestrials space travel
right yeah and here you will be able to
go to worlds afar tireless other
inhabited areas creations of god
worlds that thrilled with sorrow at the
spectacle of human woe
and rang with songs of gladness at the
tidings of a ransomed soul
with unutterable delight the children of
earth
enter into the joy and the wisdom
of unfallen beings
they share the treasures of knowledge
and understanding
gained through the ages upon ages in
contemplation of god's handiwork
now it's interesting that the new
education
tells us that we shouldn't jump too far
we should be limited
yeah and this tells us you should be
unlimited yes
with undimmed vision they gaze upon the
glory of creation
suns and stars and systems
all in their appointed order circling
the throne of deity
upon all things from the least to the
greatest the creator's name is
written and in all are the riches of his
power displayed
it's interesting that they circle the
throne of deity
there is a central point in the universe
so we will not be just
an infinitesimal spec somewhere
in the outer regions of an
enormous universe this will be the
center
of all yes now
it's interesting that people always say
you know
man was so primitive in the beginning
and we are so advanced
and some people believe you know i don't
want to go to heaven because everything
will be so
primitive yeah now who was the creator
of everything jesus christ right
and we can only harness
what has already been created yes so if
there are certain wavelengths
that exist in our realm whether they
be ultraviolet rays infrared rays
x-rays microwaves
or whatever wave we want to talk about
we can harness them and we can create
cell phones and we can create
instruments
to record them but
god created them for a purpose
and we can communicate with them we can
send information we can send pictures
across
the waves yeah now what if you
were actually an instrument
that could receive all of the waves
what if your eyes were capable of not
only
telescopic vision like an eagle
yeah but also
microscopic microscopic
so that you could actually and x-ray
vision that you could look
into something to see what the
mechanisms
are what if you were a receiver
for microwaves then you wouldn't need
a cell phone we could communicate
with each other does god know what you
are thinking
yes when angels
communicate with heaven
do they know what you are thinking yes
they must be able to read the mind now
we've discussed that
in a previous one already about
what the capability of the
restored humanity will be yeah because
we discussed it actually in that episode
where we showed that
they're trying to do this on earth
already yes with that neural link trying
plant and all this stuff
exactly they're trying to to get close
to what it was before but they won't
ever
quite be able to do it right and the
capacity that the brain has
i mean if you go to pentecost and people
were given languages
sometimes multiple languages in an
instant
there wasn't tedious study to to get
the hang of a new language right it was
instantaneous
so a brain that is so efficient that if
it sees something stores it forever
it will be amazing so is it really true
that mankind has been so primitive and
has
slowly slowly advanced to where we are
now
or were they super brilliant in the past
and we lost it all until we were
you know without wheels even at one
stage and then went
back to where we are today so let's have
a look at some of the evidence and
our people will say okay maybe they're
being conspiratorial
here is a a web page that talks about
this is actually a tourist webpage where
they take you to some of these sites
where they talk about the largest and
mysterious
ancient megalithic cut stones
of balbach lebanon i was actually there
and i looked at the ruins of the balbac
temple
and i went to the quarries where they
actually dig
these things up as you go through this
you'll see stones of that magnitude
that are cut out of solid rock
and this is a particular one that was
rejected
because it had a flaw in it but others
were transported
many miles across terrain like this
and built into temples
now this is of course a limestone
a rock and it is a post-flood phenomenon
so this comes from the post-diluvian
world
so this is just after the flood now
people are wondering
you know they must have been very
primitive people
no they were very advanced now how
advanced were they and what knowledge
did they bring with them remember they
had this
massive capacity they were huge they
were twice our size
at least twice our size if not more
and they had a technology that we can
only dream of
but we have this portrayal of evolution
that we come from monkeys
and uh cavemen and cavemen that bash
each other over the head etc
and nothing could be further from the
truth
so when we talk about some of these
technologies
then i has not seen nor eras heard what
the technologies in heaven are going to
be the technologies that you speak about
now
we don't even have technology today to
do those things we can
we cannot cut it out like that and we
cannot transport it
so how did these people do this so they
cut out these
huge stones so here's an archaeological
site in lebanon
and later it became the city of the sun
in roman times
here you can see some of these giant
buildings
and these massive stones in
the foundations and
they were built on top of of ruins
even some of them and they are
absolutely
huge i mean just look at the size of
these things they are
absolutely amazing and you ask
yourselves how did they cut them with
such precision
this one was still waiting to be
transported but it was rejected
then you have this one look at the size
of it
can we do that today now
not only do you cut it out in this
fashion you also have to cut it out from
underneath
now that other one came straight out of
the ground you can
understand how you can cut along the
edge but you must have very specific
tools right
but they are so precise is it possible
that they used lasers
but then how did they cut the underneath
that
how did you make that light go at 90
degrees to cut underneath
that's a technology we don't have yes so
there's no doubt
that this technology was absolutely
amazing there you see some of these
rocks we would not be able to transport
them and you find them all over the
world
not only at balbach
to even further complicate the enigmas
of balbach
the accuracy of the stone fitting is
remarkable
michael aloof the former curator of
the ruins wrote of the trillathon
in spite of their immense size they are
so accurately placed in position
and so carefully join that it is almost
impossible to insert a needle between
them
no description will give an exact idea
of the bewildering and
stupefying effect of these tremendous
blocks
on the spectator we don't have those
technologies today
there are other interesting things
and one of them is this researchers find
proof of ancient atomic war a great many
years
prior did our
old precursors have very trend
setting innovations matching the atomic
abilities of today
there is proof from remnants in india
supporting that guarantee
there are additionally antiquated
fantasies which depict scenes
coordinating our cutting-edge
comprehension of nuclear fighting
writings from a great many years prior
appear to contain what could be
deciphered as
precise portrayals of atomic blasts
particularly identical to the ones in
nagasaki in world war
ii take the incomparable sanskrit
epic from india called the mahabrata
it accounts fate and devastation with
entries that appear to precisely portray
the
impact and repercussions of an atomic
war now there are web pages
that talk about a worldwide war
now how long ago was that now some
webpages of course
talk about hundreds of thousands or even
millions of years
we don't have to speculate millions of
years or hundreds of thousands of years
if you start with one couple in eden
and you take current growth rates which
take into account
death and wars and famines and all of
those
issues then from one pair how long would
it take
to reach the current population of
seven billion thousand thousand two
hundred years
should do it given that growth is an
exponential
if you start with three couples as in
the days of noah
then of course it will be much shorter
so you could reach that
that number in 4 500 years
now if you had that much of a population
and at the time after noah when nimrod
built his cities and they built the
tower of babel
and the nations separated
the enemy must have been very upset with
this brilliant strategic move by god
to confuse the languages and separate
the nations
he's been trying ever since then to
unite to unite them again yes
yeah that's why he has an organization
today called the united nations
correct but god kept them separate so
that we would not
forget our dependence upon him
because if you have constant conflict
around you and you have to watch your
back you are dependent upon god right
so is it possible that there were even
nuclear wars to try and bring them
together again did they have that
technology
yes wow apparently yes apparently there
are buried cities that to this day
are still radioactive so they claim
but be that as it may here is a an
article which talks about these things
and then it gives evidence
for these very things some of these
cities
that have been abandoned
they have these great granite blocks
that have become
vitrified they've turned to glass so
there was
heat that was involved there incredible
heat like you would expect in a nuclear
explosion so maybe they weren't as
stupid as as we think
and maybe in the aftermath of such a
cataclysmic event
and we have all these impact craters
which could derive from nuclear impacts
maybe after that mankind went back into
a primitive phase
and had to rebuild many people became
isolated and became even more and more
regressive in terms of knowledge but
when you incorporate them back
into a society with knowledge very
rapidly they are capable
of learning at the same
rate as anybody else here's another one
that's very interesting
and this webpage says 17 out of place
artifacts said to suggest
high-tech prehistoric civilizations
existed
they don't understand this because their
mind can't think
of a you you have been so indoctrinated
in thinking primitive to advance
whereas in factual fact you went from
advanced to primitive
back to advanced that's what's happening
so in this webpage they talk about some
of these
things well let's just look at some of
them
and it talks about according to the
conventional views of history
humans have only walked the earth in our
present form
for some 200 000 years we won't go with
their numbers right
advanced civilizations appeared several
thousand years ago
but much of the mechanical ingenuity we
know in modern times
began to develop only around the
industrial revolution a couple of
hundreds of years ago
out of place artifacts uber art
is a term applied to dozens of
prehistoric
objects found in various places around
the world
that seemed to show a level of
technological advancement
in congress with the times in which
they were made instruments like
batteries that we do not even understand
the
technology of catholic
tubes all kinds of artifacts have been
found
metals of such purity
that we cannot even produce them in our
furnaces
to this day where do these things come
from
and if you go down and scroll down on
these web pages
you find clay jars
what they seem to say is a light bulb
walls in places where they shouldn't be
nuclear reactor sites they found
purified uranium and
that could only be as a result of a high
technology
did they have nuclear plants and what
people think about
these issues and whether you go to
brazil
or whether you go to south america or
whether you go to china or
india and uh
pipes that they found in the in the
rocks
and you know these are supposed to be
millions of years old
and yet they are buried in these sites
or instruments like this a 2 000 year
old mechanical device
used to calculate the position of the
sun moon and the stars
have been found many many interesting
artifacts here
is a metal iron
pillar that shows no rust it's a
technology
that we're not able to to
even copy in the times that we live in
and then a sword displayed in germany
which is such high quality as well the
steel
that we would think that this is not
possible in the times
that we're talking about here and then
there are other
interesting ones and now we're getting
into
very controversial errors these are
hieroglyphics
and people are saying but but what are
these things
what is that it looks like a helicopter
and what is this and of course they're
saying no it's not a helicopter this
looks like a transport
aeroplane yes and they actually found
models
of these things and they're saying no no
no this is something else it just
looks like that because mankind cannot
conceive of these things yeah that's so
here for example you have this one
compared with that one
and uh submarine submarines
interesting aeroplanes
and models such as this now
what is interesting now i'm not going to
go there i'm just
saying that we must look at the world
with different eyes
if you want to look at hidden
archaeology and what really happened in
the past
then the picture that has been portrayed
is very skew yeah the education that
they put into the world
correct why did adolf hitler
or when the war was about to start
send the largest archaeological team in
history
to egypt why did he send
rommel and his army to secure egypt
and they started these digs now he was
of course
an occultist yes and he had occult
information
and he was looking for technology yes
and we don't know to this day what he
found
we don't know what happens in those
secret laboratories
where these german scientists that came
out of that war situation
were all employed whether it was in
russia or whether it was in the united
states of america is irrelevant
where did they get hold of technologies
that suddenly exploded yeah
and brought about the times that we are
living in
all of the sudden all of a sudden and
how is it possible
that those armies in germany developed a
gps
system which was so accurate when there
were no satellites
at that stage and when you think about
these things you're wondering have we
had
the wool pulled over our eyes okay
now we don't want to speculate and we
don't want to make conspiracy theories
the fact of the matter is there is proof
enough if you want to look for it
that what existed in the past is
so technologically advanced in many
cases that we cannot comprehend it to
this day
what the anti-deluvian world looked like
we will never know
where is the antediluvian world why do
we not find
more of these things if there was a
culture pre-flood
that had millions of people probably
more than we have today
and they lived in great cities where are
these cities
now we do have cities today some of them
of the easter islands they are under the
ocean
and you can go and dive and go and see
technology there that boggles the mind
and how did they move all these things
but that's all post flood
what was it like pre-flood it is highly
probable
that that entire civilization today
is buried under the ocean
and there where the evidence of the
flood is the greatest
there humanity resided
the greatest canyons that you find on
this planet
are not where the grand canyon is but
canyons four times greater than that or
under the pacific ocean
so that means that's a flood phenomenon
so buried under that ocean are the
cities that's where you get the legends
of atlantis from
that the old civilization disappeared
under the sea
but that technology the demons know
about that technology
and here at the end of time we are
discovering
some of these things but solomon says
there's nothing new under the sun
we think we are the bees knees we are
nothing so if this is what fallen
humanity could do this is the whole
point
now forget about conspiracies forget
about this or that or
whether this is 100 accurate or that
if this is what fallen humanity can do
what is unfallen humanity going to be
capable of
all right so let's go back to our bible
and to what we can glean and
also from the spirit of prophecy and we
read here in spiritual gifts volume 3
as adam came forth from the hand of his
creator
he was of noble height
and of beautiful symmetry
he was more than twice as tall as men
now living upon earth
and was well proportioned his features
were perfect and
beautiful now
people will say but this is conjecture
no this is
what's written in the spirit of prophecy
and it is collaborated in the bible
because the bible
explains what some of these post
deluvians
were like yeah and it describes the size
of their beds
correct which is more than double of
what we have today
so this is true then the giants that
lived on the earth absolutely and then
also maybe if they just want to realize
when god created adam he created him
perfect he
created him himself correct so
now if we stand up in this building and
this building is three meters high
then adam would have to crawl in this
place right
now what were the temples like or the
buildings that they built
they must have been huge massive and
that's what we find
that's exactly what we find so his
features were perfect and beautiful
his complexion was neither white nor
sallow
but ruddy reddish
glowing with the rich tint of health
eve was not quite as tall as adam her
head reached a little above his
shoulders
she too was noble perfect in symmetry
and
very beautiful it's interesting that
symmetry actually
makes beauty the more symmetrical the
face
if you take a mirror and you look at the
one half as to the other they're very
different today they're not absolutely
perfect
and the greater the symmetry the more it
is associated with beauty
that's just a scientific little misnomer
but they were very beautiful they were
very huge they were strong
they could do things that we can only
dream of
as the years of eternity as they roll
will bring
richer and still more glorious
revelations of god and of christ
as knowledge is progressive so will love
reverence and happiness increase the
more men learn of god
the greater will be their admiration of
his character
so there are two aspects here great
technological knowledge
great opportunities that do not we
cannot even dream of yes
and then also the depth of the character
of god
to study that character of god who's
this god
that unlike any other of the deities on
this planet
was prepared to die for you and me while
we were yet sinners
unbelievable and then to bear with us as
we struggle
what about social life there we will
know
even as also we are known
there the loves and sympathies that god
has planted in the soul
will find truest and sweetest exercise
the pure communion with holy beings
the harmonious social life with the
blessed angels
and with the faithful ones of all ages
the sacred fellowship that binds
together the whole
family in heaven and on earth all are
among the experiences of the hereafter
i'd love to sit and have a chat with
paul
wouldn't you yeah well there's quite a
few people that i would like to sit down
i think we're going to have some
interesting talks one
that i've definitely got on my list is
luther
i want to talk to luther
and i want to talk to some of the
anti-diluvians
but i'll probably be get a stiff neck
from looking up and
talking to them it'll take a while to
grow
apparently you will grow in stature
until you have reached your full
potential i'm gonna take a while
to get to my full stature and you're
going to have your hair back
yeah you're going to have a crop of hair
remember
absalom yeah 3.6 kilograms
for one cut minus 3.1 milligrams
mine is even less yours is even there
psalms 29 verse 9 the voice of the lord
maketh the hinds to carve
and discover us the forests and in his
temple
does everyone speak of his glory
this is not arrogance on the part of god
you will just be
so amazed
that you will just say wow yeah don't
you think so
i'm looking forward to it someone once
said to me i may not use the word
wow okay he said it had an occult origin
so i said okay i'll only speak it
backwards from on
so what will be your occupation in the
earth made new the redeemed will engage
in the occupations and pleasures that
brought happiness to adam and eve
in the beginning the eden life will be
lived
the life in garden and field they shall
build houses and
inhabit them they shall plant vineyards
and eat the fruit of them
they shall not build and another inhabit
they shall not plant in another eat for
as the days of a tree are the days of my
people
and mine elect shall long enjoy the
works of their hands
that's an eternity their every power
will be developed every capability
increase the grandest enterprises will
be carried forward
the loftiest aspirations will be reached
without selfishness if you
read this then you can probably get a
grasp of you don't have to want to
reach all of this on earth no on this
miserable
place where we are sitting wind and
storm just sweep it away but
if if you put into the mix unselfishness
here
uh ambition to override everyone else
but just the knowledge that you can gain
and the experience and
and the joy of it unbelievable
why would you want to be here if you can
go there
the highest ambitions realized and still
there will arise new heights to surmount
new wonders to admire new truths to
comprehend
fresh objects to call forth the power
of body and mind and soul
you may study that love for ages
this is the climax getting to know
god i mean even einstein says he wants
to see the face of god
i want to see the mind of god i want to
see the character of god
i want to be able to look into his eyes
i want to be able to
see that compassion
that he had when he healed the disease
i want to be able to see it for myself
and the breadth and the depth and the
height of the love of god in giving his
son to die for the world
eternity itself can never fully reveal
it
yet as we study the bible and meditate
upon the life of christ and the plan of
redemption
these great themes will open to our
understanding
more and more and it will be ours to
realize the blessing which paul
desired for the ephesian church when he
prayed
that the god of our lord jesus christ
the father of glory
may give unto you the spirit of wisdom
and revelation
and knowledge of him the eyes of your
understanding being enlightened
that you may know what is the hope of
his calling
and what the riches of the glory of his
inheritance in the saints
and what is the exceeding greatness of
his power
to us word who believe
i don't know whether it's happened to
you
but this book here this bible
every time i read it i'm reading a new
book yeah
no it definitely happened to me does it
happen to you
it happens regularly this is the only
book i've ever read that is new every
time i read it because i discovered
things that i
never thought were even remotely written
there
and i sometimes wonder why didn't you
see that yeah
and the next time you read it you see
things again where you wonder why didn't
i see that
and sometimes you wonder i is it really
standing here i didn't know it was
standing in there
like this in the bible you know when you
give bible studies to people and they
want to
you know be otherwise and
then they confront it with a verse in
the bible which totally
shatters their world view and some will
say
no i can't accept that i'd rather accept
what my minister has to say
but i want to know what really is in
this book
because we're just scratching the
surface hebrews 10
35 and onwards cast not away therefore
your confidence which has
great recompense of reward
for you of need of patience that after
you have done the will of god
you might receive the promise for yet a
little while
and he that shall come will come
and will not tarry again i want to
reiterate
don't slip down the slippery
slope of spiritualism this is reality
it has substance now the just shall live
by
faith but if any man draw back my soul
shall have
no pleasure in him isaiah says
in chapter 35 verse 10 and the ransoms
of the lord shall return and come to
zion with songs and everlasting joy upon
their heads
they shall obtain joy and gladness and
sorrow
and sighing shall flee away
don't look at this world be in another
world
otherwise you will go insane yes
depressed how many people commit suicide
the suicide rate has soared
in this year because of all
the depression because of what is being
fed to your mouth you know yeah rather
put your hope
in this than in an earthly type
savior that will try and make some
little bit of a better place exactly
if you are in a war and you're fighting
in a trench
and you're at the point of despair
and you hear the message that tomorrow
you will be free and go back to your
wife and children your loved ones
are you going to commit suicide no
well you're going to stick it out for
another day yeah stick it out
isaiah 51 verse 3 for the lord shall
comfort zion
he will comfort all her waste places and
he will make a wilderness like
eden and a desert like the garden of the
lord
joy and gladness shall be found there in
thanksgiving and the voice of
melody you're going to sing my wife will
be so happy she loves you love singing
right yes
yes you've got this booming voice you're
such a small guy you've got this
huge voice small bottle with lots of
poison
and then it gives this promise as well
as the singers as the players on
instruments shall be there
all my springs are in the in other words
all the capacity to produce the very
best
i mean let's face it some of the music
that you listen today
is just depressing isn't it
and it's all the same and it all has the
same
beat if i switch on that radio and it
goes
then my dad used to always say
when i said to him when we let having a
party or whatever he said but it's all
the same
i said to him no but you have to listen
to this and this is all
and now i agree it's what it is
and they they add lyrics and the lyrics
because they run out of lyrics later
they are so ridiculous sometimes
that you wonder you know where's the
shakespearean element
as i chapter 24 14 says
they shall lift up their voice they
shall sing for the majesty of the lord
and they shall cry aloud from the sea
i think our croaky voices at least
mine will again join in i always thought
you know
gabriel will say uh you can play the
triangle
[Laughter]
and don't sing whatever
jude says in chapter 1 verse 24
now unto him that is able to keep you
from falling
and to present you faultless before the
presence of his glory with exceeding joy
to the only wise god and our savior be
glory and majesty dominion and power
both
now and ever
amen amen my brother
we are going home a little while
just hang in there and we will
experience things that i has not seen
nor hear us heard
looking forward to it let's pray
heavenly father thank you
for the promise of heaven
thank you for a place without pain
thank you for a place of eternal growth
in knowledge and wisdom and
understanding thank you
for the presence of the lamb that was
slain
rule the entire universe
with one harmonious note
thank you and make us able
to accept the reality of these things
and not to spiritualize them
may those who have watched be uplifted
may our thoughts be directed heavenward
is my prayer
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you